the magnitude of the equilibrium
constant tells us the relative amounts
of products and reactants at equilibrium
for example let's look at a hypothetical
reaction where gas a turns into gas b
and for the first example let's say that
gas a is represented by a red sphere and
gas b is represented by a blue sphere
and down here we have a particulate
diagram showing an equilibrium mixture
of our hypothetical reaction let's write
the equilibrium constant expression for
this hypothetical reaction so we're
going to write k c is equal to and we
think products over reactants so our
product is b so this can be the
concentration of b
and since the coefficient is a one in
the balanced equation it's the
concentration of b raised to the first
power divided by the concentration of
our reactant which is a
and a in the balanced equation also has
a coefficient of one so this is the
concentration of a raised to the first
power
if we assume that each particle in our
particulate diagram diagram represents
0.1 moles of a substance
and the volume is 1 liter we can
calculate the concentration of both a
and b
for example for b there are five blue
spheres so that would be five times
point one moles or point five moles
so for the concentration of b we have
point five moles divided by a volume of
1 liter so 0.5 divided by 1 is 0.5 molar
so we can go ahead and plug that in for
our concentration of b it's 0.5 molar
next we can do the same thing for a
there are also five red spheres and so
therefore the concentration of a is also
0.5 molar so we can plug that into our
equilibrium constant expression 0.5
divided by 0.5 is equal to 1. so
therefore k c the equilibrium constant
is equal to 1
at whatever temperature we have for our
hypothetical reaction so our equilibrium
constant kc is equal to 1 and we saw in
our particulate diagram at equilibrium
we have equal amounts of reactants and
products
therefore just by knowing the value for
the equilibrium constant we know about
the relative amounts of reactants and
products at equilibrium
let's look at another hypothetical
reaction which also has gas a turning
into gas b however this time gas a is
green and gas b is red
and let's calculate the equilibrium
constant kc for this reaction and once
again our particulate diagram shows an
equilibrium mixture so kc is equal to
the concentration of b over the
concentration of a and it's a lot faster
to simply count our particles
so for b b is red we have one red
particle here so we can go ahead and put
in
one
and then we have for for gas a we have 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 particles so 1
divided by 10 is equal to 0.1 so kc is
equal to 0.1 for this hypothetical
reaction at a certain temperature so the
magnitude of the equilibrium constant
tells us about the reaction mixture at
equilibrium
for this reaction k c is equal to 0.1 so
k is less than one and if we think about
what that means
k is equal to products over reactants so
if k is less than one that means we have
a smaller number in the numerator and a
larger number in the denominator which
means there are more reactants than
products at equilibrium
let's look at another hypothetical
reaction where gas a turns into gas b
this time gas a is yellow and gas b is
blue
if we look at our particulate diagram
showing our reaction mixture at
equilibrium there are
10 blue particles
and only one yellow particle so when we
plug into our equilibrium constant
expression this time it's going to be 10
over 1. therefore the equilibrium
constant kc is equal to 10 for this
particular reaction at a certain
temperature
once again the magnitude of the
equilibrium constant tells us something
about the reaction mixture at
equilibrium for this hypothetical
reaction kc is equal to 10 so k is
greater than one and when k is greater
than one once again we have products
over reactants so the numerator must be
larger than the denominator which means
we have a lot more products than
reactants at equilibrium
let's look at the reaction of carbon
monoxide and chlorine gas to form
phosgene at 100 degrees celsius the
equilibrium constant for this reaction
is 4.56 times 10 to the ninth
since the equilibrium constant k is
greater than 1 we know there are more
products than reactants at equilibrium
and with the extremely large value for k
like 10 to the ninth we could even
assume this reaction essentially goes to
completion
for the reaction of hydrogen gas and
iodine gas to form hydrogen iodide the
equilibrium constant kc is equal to 51
at 448 degrees celsius since the
equilibrium constant is relatively close
to 1 this means at equilibrium we have
appreciable amounts of both our
reactants and our products
let's look at the reaction of nitrogen
gas plus oxygen gas plus bromine gas to
form nobr at 298 kelvin the equilibrium
constant for this reaction is 9.5 times
10 to the negative 31st
since the equilibrium constant k is less
than 1 we know at equilibrium there are
more reactants than there are products
and with an extremely small k value like
9.5 times 10 to the negative 31st this
this reaction barely proceeds at all so
at equilibrium you can have almost all
nitrogen oxygen and bromine and very
little nobr